foreign
if you want something creamy and
decadent this is what to make
start by sauteing onions and butter
until translucent then I'm using these
imitation craft sticks although
technically these are made from fish
make the best chamel with butter and
flour and cook out the rawness for two
minutes gradually add in the milk while
whisking it's ready when it has a thick
consistency like this turn off the heat
and add a handful of cheese
and then combine it all together and
refrigerate for at least two hours
cut into six pieces and shape into a
disc and dip in flour eggs and Panko and
deep fry until they're golden brown